l'idée de se dire d'abord il doit
exister ce salaire minimum c'est ce
qu'impose la direct
[Musique]
IVe l'Europe sociale elle existe
vraiment on peut dire à travers le texte
législatif comme le salaire netatmum la
transparence des salaires
ça peut être aussi le rôle des comités
d'entreprise européennes des gros sujets
et sur lesquels on est particulièrement
qui est nous partie démocrates européen
et évidemment modem tout le sujet de la
protection sociale grâce à cette grande
transition je pense un dispositif comme
le Fond Social climat qui va permettre
d'accompagner le niveau social ces
grandes transitions porter par
Marie-Pierre vedren
[Musique]
on peut illustrer cette Europe sociale
par l'instauration d'un salaire minimum
l'idée de se dire d'abord il doit
exister ce serveur minimum c'est ce
qu'impose la directive qui a été adopté
lors de la présidence française de
l'Union européenne y compris dans des
pays où il n'y en a pas faire monter les
droits sociaux de travailleurs
leur assurer un travail décent et digne
c'est l'idée qu'il y a derrière ce texte
dans la construction de l'Europe sociale
on peut dire vraiment que nous sommes
particulièrement impliqués au Modem et
au PBE c'est dans notre ADN c'est dans
notre culture on défend une Europe aussi
humaniste et sociale et qui protège
merci Laurent pour toutes ces annonces
sociales
[Musique]